all major indices were sharply down in
early trading on wall street as the
market digested the monthly report
hopes of a reduction in the inflation
rate dashed as prices continue to rise
groceries are up by 12.2 percent over
the year rents by 5.8 percent
car prices have increased by 11.4
percent and in the largest increase
the cost of air travel has risen by 34
percent
all these attributed to americans
spending more as they emerge from the
pandemic shutdown
i'm feeling it food
i never seen it this bad i've been
noticing household products have really
shut up to the ceiling i mean honestly
like
things that was like 199 you're going
out there like six bucks you know and
things like but you need it good morning
at a meeting of house republicans it's
made clear these figures will be the
cudgel to beat democrats in the november
election new polling found that nearly
60 percent of americans say the federal
government under democrat one party rule
is to blame for today's economic crisis
the latest statistics came just hours
after president biden left on a trip to
the middle east but he's been quick to
strike back in a statement saying that
while the inflation reading is
unacceptably high it's also out of date
president biden says the data does not
reflect the true impact of the decreases
in gas prices over the last nearly 30
days the price at the pump has dropped
by some 40 cents a gallon since mid-june
the president also argues that the
report does not reflect the drop in core
inflation a long-term projection that
excludes items subject to volatile price
changes like food and energy
some experts agree the data is confusing
we've got some signs that the labor
market is incredibly robust with a large
increase in hiring according to some
surveys and a low unemployment rate
on the other hand we have uh other
concerns that
the economy is slowing down based on
slow economic growth
all eyes now on the federal reserve with
economists predicting that another
increase in interest rates is inevitable
it's a double-edged weapon
while designed to reduce inflation in
the long term in the short term an
interest hike is likely to fuel it
mike hanna al jazeera washington